our first speaker
has lived in four countries before
the sixth grade so i do think we're
going to have to ask
what those four countries were everyone
please welcome
samina hello i'm really happy to be here
and thank you so much for inviting me
and giving me the opportunity to
um to talk to you about some of my
experience in using art to study rare
diseases
and i will be talking about duchenne
muscular dystrophy
specifically but i hope that this will
be um an opportunity for
for everybody to become familiar with
some of the ideas and also some of the
ways in which you can
um ask and answer questions and rare
diseases if you're interested in getting
in
contact with me the easiest thing to do
is probably uh
twitter and actually if you go actually
my pinned tweet on twitter
is actually uh linked to this
presentation on github so you can have
all this information including my email
if you just
just go ahead and do that um okay
so uh just a quick introduction to two
rare diseases which generally have
this um this this zebra ribbon in case
you've seen it sometimes it refers to
specific diseases sometimes
just rare diseases in general so a rare
disease
in the united states it's often defined
as a disease that affects
fewer than 200 000 people um which is a
fair number of people but of course it's
very small compared to the to the us
population
and over 70 of them are genetic um
unfortunately
that means that a lot of them do affect
children especially rare diseases which
are
uh recessive so basically you need a
copy of a gene that's
um that has some issues from from both
parents um those tend to affect children
more often
um and and they lead to a substantially
reduced life expectancy
i think that they used to be called
fatal but now i think that the correct
term that people generally use is life
limiting and some
some examples that people might be
familiar with include cystic fibrosis
sickle cell anemia
some of them if they're dominant like
huntington's they might actually affect
adults but
um oftentimes they fight children and
muscular dystrophies and i'll be talking
about one of them
duchenne muscular dystrophy or dmd now
one thing about rare diseases that rare
disease advocates we like to point out
is that even though individually they're
rare as a whole they actually affect
more than 10 percent of the population
uh sorry i guess it's close to 10 of the
population it might actually be more
than that because
some of them of course might be
undiagnosed or under diagnosed due to
the rarity
so the question is what are some
approaches for for studying rare
diseases and of course since it's the
our conference you know how can we use r
and what are you know kind of some of
the priorities um in doing this
so just a quick little tidbit about this
ribbon why is it the zebra ribbon so
theodore woodward was a
very uh well known an accomplished
researcher at university of maryland
so he said when you hear who beats
behind you don't expect to see a zebra
and i guess this is especially because
in maryland uh you know where i live for
example
in maryland there are not that many
zebras right of course it depends like
where you are right context is
everything
the idea is that for example if you're
if you're a doctor
if you see a patient even if they kind
of seem to have rare symptoms they're
more likely to have a common disease
um just because just because of the
numbers right um and so the idea is that
you know rare disease advocates you want
to point out that you know there are
zebras out there so they sometimes think
of themselves as you know
medical zebra then the other thing is
that each zebra is also unique in terms
of their
described pattern so just something to
that i just wanted to share
um so some challenges with with rare
diseases there's very many challenges
including of course it can be very hard
to diagnose them right because there is
this issue of you know kind of being
like a you know
a zebra um and
it depends on what you know what the
disease is i mean there's screening now
newborn screening for some of them but
of course that's a challenge
but even post-diagnosis of course it's
an issue in terms of just performing
studies and performing clinical trials
for example
so the obvious reason of course is that
um
of course there's a very small number of
individuals affected by any
one disease and so your sample size by
definition
is going to be below so that's going to
of course be a problem
uh from a statistical point of view um
they also oftentimes have a progressive
nature unfortunately i mean it does
depend on the disease but it is often
progressive
and so there's this problem of what
clinical outcomes should you consider
because unfortunately as the disease
progresses um so for example for
addition muscular dystrophy's a muscle
wasting disease so
when children are young typically the
outcomes are how much can they walk in
in six minutes that's that's one of the
outcomes that's considered a six minute
walk test
but as it progresses and you start
having the heart being affected and the
respiratory system being affected
um and people can no longer walk then
you can't really use that outcome
anymore right so there's this issue of
like how how can you use outcomes and
then
depending on how old people are there's
different outcomes that are relevant in
your sample size can be reduced even
more
and of course if you're performing
research on children there's ethical
considerations and also in terms of
implementational challenges i think
those of us who either have children or
work with children
know that it's very hard to tell like a
five-year-old for example you know
please walk for six minutes but don't
run you know make sure you walk for six
minutes right
and uh because of some of these reasons
the fda does actually have some specific
flexibilities
when they evaluate new new therapies for
rare diseases for example by
allowing uh surrogate biomarkers to be
used instead of
instead of a specific endpoint so maybe
looking at
the impact of a drug on a protein or
i'll be talking about the impact of a
drug on a metabolite which is a small
molecule
and if you can show that that's
correlated with
a disease endpoint then you can just use
that instead of the actual disease
endpoint in the clinical drive
so um so i mentioned i'll be talking
about about dmd or duchenne muscular
dystrophy so
um it's an x-linked disorder it's you
know it's a it's a very devastating
disorder
um x-linked means that it it's caused by
mutations in the gene on the x
chromosome so this is why it affects
about one in five thousand newborn males
a lot fewer
females just because um most males
have xy chromosomes of course not not
everybody but but most of them do
and so they have a mutation in the gene
on the x chromosome they can't have
um another x chromosome like females
usually do to kind of compensate for
that so
it can happen in females as well
depending on you know if they have
mutations in both or they have some some
part that's missing or you know sort of
different situations
and there's actually work to see whether
um women who are carriers might have
some of the symptoms like maybe some
cardiac symptoms as well
but in general we people think of it as
being a disease that overwhelmingly
affects affects voice
and even though it's caused by mutations
in a single gene
it's actually the biggest gene in the in
the human genome as far as we know
and there's actually many different
kinds of mutations that can happen
in that single gene and different
mutations can actually lead to different
phenotypes so certain mutations
can actually lead to a milder phenotype
it's called vector muscular dystrophy
they used to be considered two different
diseases before people actually figured
out the genetics
and there are therapies right now some
of which are in trial some of which are
actually conditionally approved
that only target individuals with
specific mutations so that's just sort
of like
it's like a subclass of you know of a
of a small class of rare diseases and
it's an example
of of personalized medicine and you know
that's all great but again it does
complicate this situation for example
clinical drugs
um and then i mentioned you know it
leads to muscle loss and generally
unfortunately
it leads to death it's pretty rare to
live i think past like early 30s some
people live into their
late 30s but it's pretty rare um and
the mainstay treatment is still a
steroid treatment because that can help
maintain muscle mass but it can actually
cause cause issues in the long term and
it's only good for
you know maybe like a few a few years
okay so i i mentioned so there are a few
therapies that are approved or
conditionally approved
there's many clinical trials right now
actually for dmd so that's great
but again it can in some ways actually
exacerbate this issue where you
you already have a small number of
patients and you're actually having them
be competed for even more
uh in these multiple trials and then
typically i think families do actually
try to enroll their children in these
trials
but there is this issue where at a
certain point like they can kind of like
age out so i mean there's typically um
an age limit for various trials and
again it depends on on the clinical
outcomes
on the clinical symptoms it depends on
the mutation type so that is a challenge
so
one thing that you know i've tried to
get interested in is to actually look to
see what trials are actually performed
in this space and
and eventually have the goal of
developing a product that actually
allows
allows everybody who's interested in
this area to stay up to date with the
ongoing development
and also to try to prioritize um
research focusing on individuals who
maybe are
are at greatest need and um so that you
don't have like all the trials
focusing on maybe the 13 of of
individuals who have
a mutation that's amenable to exxon 51
skipping for example
um and so i had a summer student been
high
last year who looked at clinical
trials.gov which is a repository
of of the repository of all clinical
trials basically every clinical trial at
least in the u.s has to be
pre-registered
and it's all the files are xml files and
so she downloaded all the xml files that
were related to duchenne muscular
dystrophy
and the great thing about r of course is
that they're all these packages that
allow you to interact with different
kinds of files
so even though you know usually i think
about using like
tab delimited or comma delimited files
you know even if they're xml files you
can still
use the xml package and you can actually
pick out some of um
some of the the blocks that kind of the
predefined blocks and then of course
perform data cleaning that includes
things like
redundant drug names every drug i think
has at least like four names that's a
whole sort of issue onto itself
um and then she used our shiny to design
and create a web interface to explore
these trials and actually look at you
can search by condition then you can get
you can get some summary statistics and
so on and again if you if you go to my
twitter account to look at look at the
the pinned tweet you can get to the
slides and you can
you can if you want to play around with
this and take a look at it
okay so uh the second the second
vignette that i wanted to talk about was
using molecular data sets
to try to try to help out with actually
finding biomarkers of either disease
progression or drug response
so i mentioned that there's a focus in
doing this especially for
for rare diseases and we focus on
looking for
um for metabolic biomarkers so basically
metabolites which are small molecules
the study of metabolites is called
metabolomics uh they can be detected in
various
uh biofluids and tissues that includes
things like blood urine
um and so forth and they have various uh
functions and and the good thing about
them is they can be influenced by both
genetics and environment so they're sort
of like sit somewhere in between
so it's good to have you know this
opportunity to look for for different
kinds of markers and i'll be
i'll be focusing on this first paper
that we worked on from 2016.
so it this paper looked at 51 dmd
patients and 22 healthy controls
uh we detected over 2000 metabolites the
samples were all run at georgetown
in terms of the metabolomics but they
are from five different study sites so
one of the things that we were always
very
we were careful to assess is to see
whether there's any possible batch
effects and
you can see actually the individuals are
not balanced between the study sites so
we did also have
um also a sub analysis just looking at
uh calgary albert
alberta children's hospital which did
actually have a more balanced number of
patients and
healthy controls so the first step i
just i always like to
to point out the first step in doing any
sort of oh my first of all doing a lot
of data exploration making sure that
everything sort of matches up
and then i guess the second step is to
do principal component analysis
because i think that it's very revealing
in terms of you know are there batch
effects
are there artifacts when people see for
example two clusters sometimes they get
very excited like i've discovered a
pattern in my data
for me it always just makes me feel
nervous because i worry like oh doesn't
mean that actually the samples are
processed differently so
we were actually pretty happy to see
this it's just color coded by age and
this color code by study site
uh now if i was to read you right now i
would redo it a little bit differently
i just wanted to kind of have this like
as a parenthesis because i feel like i
have learned something since 2016.
so i do try to use a colorblind friendly
palette because
i'm not color blind myself so it's not
something that comes automatically but i
think about four percent of the
population is colorblind
um but so there's one of these questions
like you know how can we kind of better
automate these things so you don't have
to make these decisions right which is
kind of like tiring and like i always
you know i was like i'm like going back
and changing the color blind
friendly palette i'm trying to get to
get better at this um and then for pca
now
because it is if it's all omics so
unless you're using
different types of measurements with
different units the recommendation is
generally to actually not scale so to
use the default for example if you're
doing uh print comp
in r and also to use the same distances
on both axes
so you can see like here between zero
this is zero and ten on the y
axis zero and ten on the x axis um
because
the first principal component has more
variability than the second principal
component so it's actually ideal to try
to maintain that as opposed to having it
be a square
and i learned a lot of a lot of these
tips from this this great anguian and
homes paper
which is also a great example of
reproducibility because they actually
have the code for generating all of the
figures in their paper
so i just trying to just share that okay
so in our study so basically we had
um you know over 2000 metabolites we
basically fit a regression model for
each of them
that had at the outcome a transformed
metabolite value
log transform various other quantile
normalized and so on
um and then we we looked at how that can
be expected value can be explained by
age study site and then um disease
status of course and then also age by
disease interaction
um and we found 14 metabolites that were
significantly altered
between dmd and healthy control that a
false discovery rate of one percent
out of those 14 because of the
technology that was used we didn't know
exactly what they were we just had an
idea
of what their weight was and some other
characteristics so um
the lab that we worked with the core at
georgetown did validate them using msms
and
uh they found um four of them creatine
creatinine
uh 5a dht and testosterone sulfate we're
pretty sure that you know this is
actually what they are
and l-arginine was was likely validated
um and this is actually
it doesn't seem like a great deal but
it's actually pretty common for these
kinds of experiments it's sort of like
part of the course like most things
actually don't get validated
uh creature and creation we were happy
to see because we know that they're
actually involved
in the creatine pathway which has to do
with with things that happen in muscle
and in blood
and you see creatine and creatinine here
so these are both metabolized they're
small molecules
and this reaction here is catalyzed by
creatine kinase protein kinase is a
protein so we didn't pick it up in our
study because it's too large
but actually our team did do some
members of our team could actually do a
proteomics study where they picked up
creatine kinase
and this is actually a very um a very
well-known biomarker
uh a very well-known diagnostic
biomarker of dmd so it shows up being at
very high levels
in sort of children between the ages of
maybe like four and ten
or so um because it shows that there's a
lot of a lot of like muscle
muscle damage going on so typically if
somebody is suspected of having dmd
they'll have a blood test or they look
at ck levels and typically those will be
way way higher than in
you know healthy healthy individuals but
the problem is that would age
as you know there's muscle wasting going
on and so would age that actually
goes down a lot and so you can't really
use it as a biomarker of disease
progression or
therapy response but in any case it was
good it was good to see
to see these as some of our some of our
among our results
and we also considered in a post-hoc
fashion the ratio between
creatine and creatinine because you see
that like one of them leads to the other
so they're actually inversely
related so their ratio is actually even
more um
it's actually even more compelling to
look at it so you can see between
dmd and controls they're they're
generally very very different
and it has a very low p-value but i mean
this was this was a kind of a post-hoc
analysis
uh but we were actually happy to see
this result validated by by another
group so that was that was good
um another thing i just i want to talk
about so in terms of doing this work i
think it's important to keep in mind
that there is kind of this i call it
like a study
ecosystem like what's going on beyond
the paper and you can think of this as
sort of
being related to reproducibility you
know reproducibility powered by r i
think that's one of the big benefits
of r so i know some people have have
said that a scientific article or a
report
it's sort of like advertising the
research because you're only kind of
getting
maybe like a big picture of you finding
out you know about like specific
decisions that were made
maybe in order to to have um to have
a certain result or a certain
publication but there's a lot that's
actually
kind of going on behind the scenes um
this is published by
in place and so plot always wanted to
deposit the data you know
as much as possible and so we deposited
the raw data and triad which is one of
the repositories that they recommend
and then the process data along with the
analysis code is on github
and they're all linked and ideally you
know you can you can get all the links
so they're all linked for example from
my website
i think it would be great to to figure
out some some better ways in the
community to sort of connect all these
things i mean there's also like links
you know in the in the paper but um it's
one of those things where again i think
if you kind of incentivize it and sort
of make it be automatic so that people
don't have to kind of think about
doing all of these things and kind of
figure out you know like every time you
know like i update my cv and it's like
you have to like kind of copy and paste
like five different links i think it
would be great to have
a more a more automated way of doing
that just like it would be great to have
maybe like you know i color blind
friendly palettes would just be the
default so you don't have to think
through it and make you know make more
decisions about it yourself
um so just some of the conclusions so
primarily for the for the metabolic
study so the 2016 study that i talked
about
we're very proud that it was the first
comprehensive metabolomic study for
producing muscular dystrophy and we
thought it was one of the first steps in
finding
metabolic surrogate biomarkers and
adding to
this list because people have looked at
other kinds of of uh you know like
proteomics and looking at
mrna markers and so on and we also had a
2020 study which looked at
the urine of mice so there's a mouse
model called the mdx model and we
compared
um healthy mice with mdx mice and then
um
they either were just taking a control
or they were on prednisolone which is a
type of corticosteroid so we got some
additional biomarkers from that as well
so some future goals in terms of also uh
combining this
with um with what i talked about in
terms of clinical trials i think it
would be really great to have these
types of studies embedded into clinical
trials because
clinical trials have very clean data
they have very good
clinical outcomes and so then it's a lot
i think it's a lot easier if you can
just have access to some of these
samples
where people have already you know the
the people who set up the clinical
trials are already measuring a lot of
these
a lot of these outcomes on the study
participants and then you can also do
kind of some omics sort of like on the
side i mean it has to be embedded into
the protocol but it now would be sort of
like
the ideal thing to do and i also tried
to connect this type of study with
genetic data and focus it on some of the
you know i mentioned the areas of
greatest need in terms of maybe looking
at people who
aren't served by current trials in some
way right either because they have a
rare mutation or because of their age or
because of some other
some other um aspects
okay so just this is just that i just
wanted to acknowledge all the people who
are involved in the study our funding
the study participants
um including these are three students
who who helped me out they weren't
involved in the original publications
because they started working
with me on this afterwards but uh bin
was involved in the
um in the clinical trials work and then
uh boyun and chintang are looking more
at the
metabolomics data we also did some
metabolomics proteomics integration
again if anybody's interested you know
definitely feel free to contact me
afterwards if anybody wants to talk more
about it
and just this is just my final
advertisement slide so we have
a master's program in health informatics
and data science at georgetown
um it's a great program if i say so
myself i'm one of the faculty in it
um we're in our second year right now so
we're open for applications for next
year definitely let me know
it also includes it's a one year program
that includes um a summer
sort of internship with industry which
is co-mentored by by a faculty member as
well
and um you know i i recently joined our
ladies dc as a co-organizer and i know
that our ladies is also involved in
setting up this meeting so
these are some of the twitter accounts
for our ladies global and our ladies dc
and of course there are ladies chapters
in many
many cities in the u.s and the world so
uh thank you so much
thank you very much uh that does remind
me thank you for the reminder we are
going to have an our ladies photo
let me just check when that is supposed
to be